vital causes
are the things that we seek above all
others the things we would die for
[Music]
if you read the dictionary of
independence you will find that it comes
in three parts and in the first part it
states some universal principles very
beautiful
and in the second part it contains a
bill of particulars in 17 paragraphs
about bad stuff the king of england did
which bad stuff justifies the making of
america throwing off the old government
and
adopting a new one
and those things are
remarkably liked the constitution united
states what did the king do wrong well
he interfered with the legislature
which is a violation of the first step
in all government the making of laws but
also a violation of separation of powers
which is crucial to how the constitution
the united states worked
so separation of powers is important and
then he interfered with the people's
ability to elect
legislators in other words
representation
a key feature of the constitution of the
united states
and then he interfered with the judges
he would
ship people
arrest them for crimes and ship them off
to england where they couldn't be tried
by a jury of their peers nor before
judges who were independent of the
executive branch which more or less the
king was
so you see
they're writing the constitution right
there
if you have a government that does these
things then you are justified to rebel
against that government and to kill
anybody who resists you
so it implies the constitution
now what kind of thing that they are
different to that christ independence
and the constitution they serve
different functions
they also sound different in a very
interesting way
the declaration independence is really
beautiful
[Music]
you know when in the course of human
events it becomes necessary for one
people to dissolve the political bands
that have connected them with another
and to assume among the powers of the
earth to separate an equal station
which the laws of nature and nature's
god entitle them isn't that a grand
expression the laws of nature and of
nature's god
it's written like that
also it's not time bound
uh when in the course of human events
that means any time in the course of
human events it becomes necessary for
one people that means any people
anywhere anytime the claim is
what's going to follow in this document
is right
at all times
and so one way to think about the
difference between the dichroism and the
constitution is
it's a
document about ultimate purposes
what they call in classic philosophy
final causes
vital causes
are the things that we seek above all
others the things we would die for
well the constitution is not quite like
that uh
the constitution is uh
it provides a form of government
and when you read it
you know i've regarded it as beautiful
and think i understand why it's
beautiful it has to do with its
structure which madison says is the most
important thing about it
but
you know on
any given passage
right
um it's full of details like there's a
list in article 1 section 8
things the congress can do
well
post offices and post roads is among
them
it's hard to write a beautiful sentence
about that no this is a document about
how the government is going to work even
how it's going to look
it looks like a thing that operates in
three branches
if the if if there's a interviews going
on in front of the white house which
there are every day on the nightly news
there's a picture of the white house in
the background because that's where the
president works and that's where
executive things are done
and if there's a
if there's something big in the congress
then there's
uh cameras looking up at the capitol
dome because that's where the congress
operates and where the legislation is
made and the same for the supreme court
building
in operation the government looks like
the constitution and so
it's become a very great country
in the course of its history
beyond the imaginings even
of the people who founded it who were
extremely ambitious people
they had the highest possible hopes
well if that's true
there must have been some cause of it
but also it's in that final purpose
we serve that we have adopted it's a
purpose available to all human beings
we have adopted it for our own
thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore all of
hillsdale college's online courses they
are free and for everyone who loves to
learn